[Musica]
12 aprile 1961 il cosmonauta Russo Yuri
Gagarin sale sulla vostra Q1 e viene
lanciato nello spazio
prima di lui ufficialmente sovietici
Hanno lanciato nello spazio sette razzi
tre sono tornati a terra quattro sono
esplosi Eppure Yuri sale sulla vostra Q1
ed è contento e dice più o meno tutto
quello che ho fatto nella vita si sta
per condensare qui adesso in questo
meraviglioso momento tutto quello a cui
ho pensato tutto quello che ho
progettato fin qui si sta per realizzare
Yuri raggiungerà l'altitudine di 302 km
dalla superficie terrestre la velocità
di
27.400 chilometri orari completerà
un'orbita ellittica della terra e
tornerà qui dopo poco meno di due ore
atterrerà con il suo paracadute su un
campo di patate nella oblast di Saratov
vicino al villaggio di smelòca su
un'ansa del fiume Volga e i primi
terrestri che incontrerà saranno una
contadina di nome Anna e la sua nipotina
di 6 anni è iniziata l'era spaziale
Dopo questo volo di Yuri Gagarin le
reazioni furono molte per esempio
qualche anno più tardi il 24 dicembre
del 1967 sul Corriere della Sera Anna
Maria Ortese scrisse una lettera aperta
a Italo Calvino Italo Calvino che aveva
appena pubblicato The conjero che come
saprete è il seguito delle cosmicomiche
e di con zero in linguaggio scientifico
significa il momento in cui ho
cominciato a osservare e Annamaria
Ortese scrive più o meno
tutte le volte che sento parlare di voli
spaziali mi sale l'ansia la paura la
noia lo sgomento Insomma anch'io come
ogni altro essere umano mi sono fatta
delle domande sull'universo sul suo
inizio sulla sua fine e il silenzio che
ho avuto in risposta li ho trovati
consolatori
E allora adesso vedo scrivere Anna Maria
Ortese lo spazio sottratto ai nostri
sogni non la dice proprio così lei dice
sottratto al nostro desiderio di beltà e
trasformato in uno spazio edilizio in un
territorio di conquista Ecco questo non
mi piace sulle stesse pagine del
Corriere della Sera risponde Italo
Calvino sempre con una lettera aperta e
in cui dice più o meno io non pretendo
che ci sia passioni all'esplorazione
dello spazio però questo mi interessa
per tutta la scienza che c'è dietro per
la conoscenza che produce e per come
questa conoscenza ci ridefinisce
ridefinisce noi esseri umani e lo spazio
extraumano intorno a noi come ci porta a
ridefinire persino la luna
e poi dice Italo Calvino tutto questo
ridefinisce anche il nostro immaginario
il nostro linguaggio che sono territori
propri della letteratura e ovviamente
questo mi interessa molto Allora
l'obiezione di Anna Maria Ortese è
un'obiezione che noi che facciamo
scienza ci sentiamo rivolgere spesso la
scienza con la sua esplorazione della
natura con la sua spiegazione delle cose
ruberebbe lo spazio ai nostri sogni
sporchizzerebbe la natura la
sottrarrebbe Al desiderio di beltà
lasciate da parte la risposta che da
Italo Calvino e facciamo un passo avanti
e allora adesso 20 luglio 1969
l'astronauta americano Nils Armstrong
poggia il suo piede sinistro sulla
superficie della Luna quell'impronta è
ancora là è ancora sulla regolite che è
la sabbia della superficie della Luna
Nizza Armstrong prima di quell'impronta
ha viaggiato per quattro giorni è stato
lanciato da che Canaveral con i suoi due
colleghi lui è il comandante della
missione Apollo 11 e con lui ci sono
pilota del modulo di comando Colombia e
che Michael Collins e il pilota del
modulo lunare il Lem Eagle quello che
toccherà poi la superficie lunare per
secondo cioè basa aldrin dopo aver
toccato la luna nel sarnostrong torna
indietro e dopo quattro giorni ritorna
qui sul nostro pianeta lui non atterra
lui ammara Cioè si butta nell'oceano
Pacifico quindi probabilmente i primi
terrestri che avrà incontrato saranno
stati dei Pesci In ogni caso è iniziata
Scusatemi In ogni caso l'essere umano ha
conquistato la luna Ecco di nuovo tante
reazioni questa volta pochi giorni dopo
nell'agosto del 1969 Pierpaolo Pasolini
scrive sulla sua rubrica che si intitola
il caos sul quotidiano Il tempo una cosa
che dice più o meno così Beh la
conquista della luna è sicuramente una
grande notizia Ma come mai non interessa
nessuno Io sono qui sul set di un film
dice per Paolo Pasolini e Saremo circa
40 persone più ci sono le maestranze
bene nessuno ne sta parlando e anche sul
giornale trovo molto più spazio dedicato
alla partita Milan - Manchester e poi
prosegue Pasolini a me infastidisce
anche il nome Apollo un richiamo
umanistico assolutamente inadatta
un'impresa che ha solo tecnologica e poi
mi stanno sulle balle gli astronauti
così Borghesi con questi figlioli biondi
e le mogli che servono il caffè
tante altre reazioni ma una tra tra le
tante fu una specie di risposta
implicita a Pierpaolo Pasolini ed è
quella di Giuseppe Ungaretti Giuseppe
Ungaretti ha 81 anni in questo momento e
non è mai stato un personaggio votato
all'ottimismo ha avuto una vita anche
complicata Orfano la guerra ha perso due
figli Insomma Giuseppe Ungaretti eppure
in quel momento è lì che brinda e si fa
fotografare da un importante fotografo
brinda col televisore il televisore che
trasmette le immagini dell'allunaggio
Ecco furono in tanti dicevo a reagire
alle immagini della conquista della
superficie lunare e già in questo
smentirono quello che che diceva
Pierpaolo Pasolini cioè che la cosa non
fosse per niente interessante alcuni
intellettuali italiani erano peraltro
negli studi RAI proprio quella notte
altri ne scrissero in articoli Tanti ne
scrissero le loro libri o fecero per
colare la l'esperienza lunare nei loro
testi e non pensiamo soltanto a Calvino
Rodari che sono i primi che ci vengono
in mente bene in tanti reagirono e una
domanda per tutti era di fondo e questa
domanda è di nuovo una domanda che noi
che ci occupiamo di scienza ci sentiamo
spesso fare perché perché lo facciamo
perché dovremmo farlo perché spendiamo
tante energie in cose come questa Tra le
tante risposte vi Cito quella di Primo
Levi Primo Levi non è bene una reazione
entusiasta né una reazione di biasimo la
conquista della Luna Lui scrisse più o
meno ci sono tante ragioni per farlo ma
una tra tutte le guida sta dietro le
altre ed è la nostra oscuro obbedienza a
un istinto nato con la vita e alla vita
necessario lo stesso istinto Anzi lui
dice impulso che spinge I semi del
Pioppo ad avvolgersi di bambagia e a
volare nel vento cioè l'impulso ha
sparpagliarci
Ecco la risposta che da Primo Levi è una
risposta che io trovo particolarmente
interessante si parla della nostra
natura e si dice che la nostra ricerca
sulla natura fa parte della nostra
natura Insomma è la natura che guarda se
stessa in questo come fa a essere poco
interessante o a far mancare di poesia
alle cose è una risposta che è stata
data tante volte nel corso appunto del
Novecento che è stato un anno di grande
scienza vi Cito Un altro importante
scienziato Anzi un importante scienziato
lui è stato un premio Nobel tra i più
importante per la fisica nel secolo
scorso Richard feyman lui in una
trasmissione radiofonica raccontò Più o
meno ho un amico poeta l'amico poeta mi
dice che noi scienziati rubiamo La
poesia ai fiori e io gli ho risposto
così Beh no come essere umano anch'io
vedo la poesia Nel fiore non puoi
negarlo non puoi dire che io vedo cose
diverse da quelle che vedi tu Però io
posso affermare di vederne di più perché
la vedo su un altro livello per esempio
sul livello microscopico posso farmi
domande per esempio sul contenitore dei
petali del fiore e anche su come gli
insetti li riconoscano e in questa cosa
nel colore del petalo e nell'insetto che
lo riconosce io vedo una meravigliosa
storia d'amore la storia di una
coevoluzione E allora conclude Final io
non vedo proprio come la scienza possa
togliere qualcosa al mondo Semmai
aggiunge Ecco questa è una risposta che
Chiama in causa appunto la nostra
naturalità e che secondo me dobbiamo
tenere sempre di conto se chiudiamo gli
occhi di fronte alla nostra a nostro
istinto di fare ricerca di cercare di
capire le cose intorno a noi perdiamo
molto anche di noi e anche del nostro
come diceva Annamaria Ortese desiderio
di beltà
ve lo dico con le parole di Uno sì dei
grandi scienziati di sempre di Giovanni
Keplero Keplero scrisse più o meno i
modi in cui gli uomini si sono
interrogati sulle cose celesti sono
altrettanto meravigliosi delle cose
celesti stesse insomma siamo sempre noi
è sempre la nostra natura siamo sempre
lì Certo bisogna dire una cosa la
scienza non la facciamo soltanto perché
wow eh Wow ma è anche molto utile
risolvere i nostri problemi pensate alla
ricerca biomedica migliora la qualità
delle nostre vite ci fa fare cose che
altrimenti non potremmo fare e poi sì è
vero ogni tanto la facciamo anche perché
ci dà ricchezza o la facciamo anche come
è stato parte Nel caso dell'esplorazione
dello spazio per ragioni militari e non
dobbiamo negarlo ed è anche vero che
dobbiamo farci insieme delle domande
dobbiamo cercare insieme delle risposte
insieme ma tutto questo non è meno Wow È
molto naturale anche questo è molto
umano anche questo
e poi c'è Un'ultima cosa che vi voglio
dire che forse è quella che avrei dovuto
dire subito nel mio ruolo Cioè ci sono
quelli come me che hanno il compito di
raccontarla la scienza perché tutto
questo anche il modo con cui ne parliamo
dipende dal modo con cui la raccontiamo
e uno dei nostri compiti e anche quello
di parlare alle Anne Maria ortesi tra
voi o Pierpaolo Pasolini tra voi cioè
quelli che hanno un po' paura un po'
diffidenza un po' pensano di poterne
fare a meno per cercare di convincervi
che tutto sommato no no guardatevi Siete
degli esploratori Siamo esseri umani
siamo fatti così come mai guardare il
resto della natura dovrebbe essere meno
naturale che farlo seguendo un istinto
che è molto naturale e allora proviamo a
ricordarla torniamo lì un po' più di 60
anni fa su quell'ansa del Volga oblast
di Saratov villaggio di smelò these
melovka un campo di patate Ci sono due
esseri umani che si incontrano uno è
Yuri Gagarin e l'uomo del momento ne sta
parlando tutto pianeta è stato
extraterrestre per due ore e poi è
atterrato lì un altro è una contadina
China sulle sue patate insieme alla sua
nipotina peraltro lei lì per lì è anche
molto spaventata Quindi lui si deve
presentare lei capisce chi è ma insomma
lo sapete cosa fanno un istante dopo un
istante dopo essersi guardati e
riconosciuti e capiti come esseri umani
Beh si abbracciano e in quella braccio
Io credo che ci fosse quell'emozione
molto umana che ci guida a cercare le
cose e sapete qual è la meraviglia
Grazie
[Applauso]